aaron yeager the main character in
attack on titan had quite a lot of
transformations throughout the anime not
only did his character change from an
immature child to a complex mastermind
but his titan form also transformed in
the latest season and it was shocking to
say the least let's go through how
exactly aaron acquired this godly power
and what he used it for
during the war with marley zeke sides
with paradise and aaron fights against
the armored titan zeke is shot in the
nape and pretends to die while aaron
uses hardening to trap reiner he then
starts running towards zeke but is
decapitated by gabby aaron's head goes
flying and zeke tries to catch it in his
hand the contact is made and the two
brothers end up in the paths a location
that connects the subjects of emir
together in the paths aaron revealed his
true intentions for protecting paradise
and destroying the outside world whereas
zeke also reveals how he used aaron just
so he can unlock the true powers of the
founding titan using it to carry out his
plan of sterilizing the subjects of ymir
zeke then tries to convince aaron that
he is being controlled by grisha and
chosen grisha's memories however he
realizes that aaron was the one who
actually manipulated grisha and was
given the freedom that zeke never had as
a child zeke then chains aaron and
commandemiere to put a stop to the
bloodline of the aldians aaron breaks
his chains and goes after ymir he
convinces her that she no longer has to
be a slave to the royal family and that
he will set her free ymir grants him the
full power of the founding titan and
aaron is seen transforming in the shigen
china district into a monstrosity of a
titan the founding titan's spine
connected with aaron's decapitated head
which led to him being larger than even
the wall titans his transformation undid
all kinds of hardening releasing the
wall titans and even destroying annie's
crystal the wall titans started marching
towards other countries laying waste to
anything in their path aaron then
communicated with all the aldians
through paths and told them that he was
coming for them the marlian soldiers
immediately started to retreat and only
a few remained on the island the
warriors theo maggath and the survey
corps started working together to stop
aaron from completely destroying the
outside world aaron in his founding
titan form is extremely powerful and is
even capable of summoning all the
previous incarnations of the nine titans
he used the previous incarnations to
fight against the warriors and the
survey corps however during the fight
some of the titans chose to fight with
the survey corps instead meaning they
had control over their thoughts and
actions to a certain point zeke also
emerges from the spine and is
decapitated by levi which stops the
rumbling gene then detonates the
explosives blowing off the founding
titan's head a centipede like creature
emerges which tries to connect to
aaron's head but reiner tries to keep it
in place armin then tries to blow away
the founding titan by transforming into
his colossal titan however even this
doesn't stop aaron and he emerges from
the rubble in his colossal titan form
levi ackerman then shoots a
thundersphere into aaron's mouth
creating an opening for mikasa she
enters through his mouth and then kills
him with a single swing of her blade
aaron dies in mikasa's arms as she
kisses him farewell thereby freeing him
of his burdens and freeing the amir as
well in short in his founding titan form
aaron spread destruction outside of the
island of paradise and has killed almost
80 of humanity he was extremely strong
to the point that all the countries
combined did not have the technology to
tackle him what's more his appearance
was quite terrifying as well aaron's
founding titan looked quite bizarre and
terrifying at the same time as it was
constructed of only bones it was quite
massive compared to most pure titans and
even the colossal titans in the wall the
exact height has not been shared but
based on the manga panels we can assume
that it's at least 250 meters tall the
reason why it's so large is due to the
special conditions during which aaron
unlocked the power of the founding titan
aaron's head was far away from his body
when the power was unlocked leading the
founding titan's spine to grow longer
and connect to erin's decapitated head
the spine kept growing to the point that
it ended up looking like a massive and
horrifying skeletal frame aaron's
appearance is not the only thing that
separates him from other founding titan
users he also has many unique powers and
abilities ymir fritz gave the full power
of the founding titan to aaron which he
displayed well in the war against marley
and the other nations the most obvious
ability he had was memory manipulation
which allowed him to alter or even erase
the memories of the aldians aaron used
this power to temporarily steal the
memories and meetings with his friends
especially the memories of his meeting
with armin after aaron died armin
remembered the time aaron visited him
and shared his true feelings with him
the memory manipulation technique was
also used by king carl fritz to alter
the memories of the aldians inside the
wall he made them forget about the truth
of the outside world making them think
that humanity outside the walls doesn't
exist it's important to mention that the
memory manipulation technique doesn't
work against the members of the
ackermann clan as they belong to the
non-aldean bloodline the most powerful
and terrifying ability that eren
possessed as the founding titan was the
rumbling when aaron got the full powers
of the founder the hardening of the
walls and the other titans were undone
and the wall titans were released they
started marching across the land on
aaron's command furthermore aaron's
scream is also capable of controlling
the pure titans and commanding them as
he pleases aaron first demonstrated this
power when he came into contact with the
titan of dina frets and unknowingly
commanded the pure titans to devour her
ymir fritz has also used the ability to
command the titans to perform many tasks
include building the kingdom of aldia
aaron's founding titan is also capable
of summoning all the previous nine titan
holders it's capable of summoning an
infinite number of titans with the help
of mere frets aaron summoned the ancient
titan shifters on his spine to fight
against marley and the survey corps he
used them to keep his enemies at bay so
he can proceed with his plan and
annihilate the entire world outside of
paradise what's really impressive about
this ability is that the ancient titan
shifters looked very much alive and
possessed the same abilities as they did
when they were alive this particular
power of the founding titan proved to be
quite troublesome for the survey corps
but they managed to find a way around it
another ability unique to the founding
titan is that it can turn any of the
aliens into titans as it wishes aldians
can be transformed into massive colossal
titans as well this technique was
demonstrated by king karl fretts by
creating the wall out of the 50 meter
titans what's even more interesting is
that aaron doesn't require any special
conditions to activate this power unlike
zeke who needs to first inject his
spinal fluid into the target as the
founding titan aaron could transform
into any of the nine titans as he wished
he demonstrates this ability when his
head is blown away and he transforms
into the colossal titan to fight against
armin the nine titans each possess
unique abilities and to be able to
transform into any of them makes aaron
the most terrifying enemy of humanity
another ability that aaron gained after
unlocking his founding titan powers was
the ability to connect with all the
aldians of the paths he used telepathic
communication to relay his message of
the rumbling to all eldins around the
world furthermore he also used this
ability to talk to armin one last time
and share with him his true feelings
about the entire situation regarding the
war and why he made all the decisions he
even told him how he felt about mikasa
but then he temporarily altered armin's
memory so he doesn't remember any of the
details till aaron dies moving forward a
very unique ability that the inheritor
of the founding titan possesses is being
able to change the anatomy of subjects
of ymir zeke eager's ultimate wish was
to euthanize the aldians and he even
commanded ymir to do so additionally
king carl fritz also used this ability
to make the aldians immune to an
epidemic in that era therefore keeping
this information in mind aaron as the
inheritor of the founding titan is also
capable of doing so and can command
yumir to make certain changes to the
anatomy of the aldians aaron also
possesses the ability to foresee the
future and directly impact the past as
well this power is the result of
controlling both the founding titan and
the attack titan at the same time
however this can also affect the mindset
of the inheritor as they are unable to
think coherently and end up going with
the flow of the events that is exactly
what happened to aaron as well as he
controlled the past to indirectly make
dinafrits devour his mother aaron also
encouraged grisha to end the royal
bloodline and eat the founding titan
grisha had no intention of killing
children but he did so because aaron
manipulated him so what about the
previous inheritance of the founding
type is aaron more powerful compared to
them let's compare them to grisha frida
and the emir as the founding titan
inheritor aaron was far more powerful
compared to his father and frida reese
frieda was a descendant of the royal
bloodline and was bound by the vow to
renounce war she was not given the full
powers of the founding titan because of
the vow and that's why she couldn't
fight back against grisha similarly
grisha was not given the full powers of
the founding titan as well and he
immediately passed his powers to aaron
so what about yamir fritz then compared
to ymir aaron is quite weak and that is
quite understandable ymir was the first
one to receive the powers of the
founding titan and is also the one who
gave aaron the powers as well if aaron
hadn't convinced emir she would have
never given him the powers of the
founding titan therefore it's safe to
assume that emir fritz is far more
powerful than era click on this video
where we explained all secret john
titans in attack on titan trust me you
really want to see this video